so harry and megan are under fire for
finding freedom let's bring in nichelle
turner she's working from new york city
this weekend michelle oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy is right kevin frazier
remember when this book came out in the
summer of 2020 and while the sussex has
denied they had any part of it a new
bombshell claim says they were in on it
all along
the term mexic is a misogynistic term
and it was created by a troll
i would urge you not to read tabloids
this is toxic for your mental health
sixteen hours after blasting the british
tabloids megan's privacy lawsuit in a
london appeals court took a dramatic
turn there is an element of hypocrisy
here mr klaus witness statement says he
has multiple conversations with her
about his book time
private text and emails were read in
court including one from harry i totally
agree that we have to be able to say we
didn't have anything to do with it we
hope to get some truths out there
did harry and megan help you with
finding freedom
on multiple occasions finding freedom
co-author omit scobee denied to us ever
working with harry and megan no
cooperation from the couple whatsoever
did you you worked with harry and megan
as i've said before harry and megan
didn't take part in the process of this
book
another bombshell claim megan suspected
her private letter to her estranged
father could be leaked and carefully
chose to address him as daddy allegedly
writing obviously everything i have
drafted is with the understanding that
it could be neat
so i have been meticulous in my word
choice and in the unfortunate event that
it leaked it would pull the heartstrings
megan's team doubled down this morning
in a 20-page response the duchess
maintained she never cooperated with
finding freedom's authors you must stand
up for what's right and that's what i'm
doing
[Music]